sherbrooke sitter chers footballeurs ou
pas le temps d apple
c'est pas complètement fini wacker le
président boris johnson somme pour
certains la fin de la première ligne
exit ce visa et passe droits ou welcome
protectionnisme et repli sur soi et ce
alors que 331 footballeurs étrangers
évolué cette année dans le championnat
de sa majesté et ce titre elle était
bien le foot anglais pourrait perdre de
son attractivité de sa compétitivité des
clubs les plus riches
manchester liverpool arsenal chelsea
pourrait-il devenir encore plus riche
les clubs les plus pauvres vont-ils
devenir encore plus pauvres et qu'un
impact sur le moral des supporters
britanniques pour qui le foot est une
bouffée d'oxygène dans un quotidien
parfois incertains on en parle après le
générique
ouais
[Musique]
bienvenue sur rt france pour un nouveau
numéro de l'autre match un peu plus d'un
mois après le brésil le 31 janvier
dernier on se pose cette question quel
avenir pour le foot anglais
quelles conséquences du divorce entre
londres et bruxelles sur ce plateau et
gérard houillier ex manager de liverpool
bonjour merci d'être sur ce plateau est
à vos côtés
david cros à une journaliste anglaise
spécialisée foot bonjour bonjour avant
de rentrer dans le vif du sujet je vous
propose de regarder un sondage on a posé
cette question sur les réseaux sociaux
aux internautes le président va-t-il
tuer le foot anglais
oui à 8% et non 92% votre avis gérard
houllier quand on voit ce sondage ça
vous inspire quoi
je partage leur avis et vous à david
moyes tout à fait alors du coup si vous
partagez cet avis pourquoi est-ce qu'on
se pose cette question pourquoi est ce
que certains se demandent si le brésil
peut avoir des conséquences sur le foot
anglais on parle notamment de de visa de
permis de travail ce sera beaucoup plus
compliqué est-ce qu'il peut y avoir des
conséquences et si oui lesquelles
il y aura probablement deux attitudes
une soit un soft bauxite soit un arbre
existe si c'est un arabe briques sites
comme vous dites valley club tel que
arsenal manchester liverpool et consorts
ne pourront plus acheter des joueurs qui
n'ont pas été internationaux c'est un
bon petit joueur sur lequel il mise pour
l'avenir parce que il ya un certain
nombre de critères et pour obtenir un
permis de travail
un peu parce que ils vont être
considérés comme des nos news lundi oui
c'est à dire des non européens et donc
ils vont forcément ils ont répondre de
répondre à certains critères ça
s'apprend disons de pourcentage de
participation de tubes compétition
officielle des équipes nationales
mais justement avec ces nouveaux
critères avec ces nouvelles barrières
qui vont être mises en place
est-ce que ça va pas à rendre une
championnat anglais un petit peu moins
attractif un peu moins compétitifs david
savard restait le championnat le plus
riche et
pendant assez longtemps sauf s'il ya une
chute spectaculaire de l'économie
britannique qui peut se passer
on ne sait pas encore pour tout on sait
pas encore est ce que le taux des
changes va rester tel quel parce que on
souhaite y ouvre quasiment au même
niveau qu'au moment du référendum en
juin 2016
ce qu'on sait que les conduira de celles
et ceux là où le football anglais est
très four sont en train de négocier pour
la période après 2022 et la seconde en
libye vient de signer pour 2 milliards
saucisson c'est un contrat énorme et ça
prouve à l'actualité la tracabilité de
football anglais qui vont publie ce
concept un peu le championnat locaux
vous parlez de des droits télés 1 4 8
milliards par an pour les clubs anglais
sur la période 2010 9 2029 donc c'est
plus 30% les chiffres selon sur l'équipe
évidemment vous parlez de contrats à
l'étranger
mais malgré tout cela il y à des
déclarations aussi
à droite à gauche par rapport au brésil
je pense notamment à mauricio pochettino
à l'ancien
l'ancien manager de tottenham qui avait
déclaré dans independence il ya il parle
la construction du stade le nouveau
stade qui coûte presque 1,1 milliard
d'euros
c'est la vérité ne croyez pas qu'ils ne
coûtent que 450 millions d'euros
je cite avec le brésil c'est plus cher
car le prix augmenter de 30% c'est un
drame je suis désolé pour les anglais
donc qui met bien des conséquences du
bre exit sur l'économie anglaise et sur
le football anglais
là c'est sur la parité au niveau du taux
de change c'est pour ça que cette époque
là c'est vrai qu'il ya une chute disons
de la livre maintenant comme l'expliqué
david ils sont revenus pratiquement au
même niveau que il ya cinq ans vous
parlais tout à l'heure des
la complexité du permis de travail des
visas je vous propose de regarder ce
sujet de clément delcourt pour
comprendre un petit peu mieux la
complexité de la chose cette saison 3
131 joueurs étrangers évoluant en 1re
ligue
chaque semaine les clubs peuvent jouer
sans aligner le moindre anglais l'an
dernier finale de ligue europa entre
chelsea arsenal
un seul britannique sur les 22
titulaires mais le brésil pourrait bien
tout chambouler des clubs anglais ne
pourront plus attirer les talents
européen avant qu'ils ne soient majeurs
la fifa interdisant aux joueurs de moins
de 18 ans de rejoindre un club étranger
à moins que ce dernier ne fasse partie
de l'union européenne
entité dont le royaume-uni ne fait plus
partie une restriction qui aurait
empêché manchester united de recruter
paul pogba lorsqu'il était encore au
havre en 2009
il était âgé de 16 ans autres
réglementations le permis de travail
obligatoire pour tous les joueurs
étrangers même européen et cela pourrait
grandement compliquer le recrutement
puisque chaque joueur devra remplir
plusieurs critères
par exemple être international est
comptabilisé un certain nombre de
sélections avec son équipe nationale
cette dernière devra également bien
figurer au classement fifa pour que le
joueur soit éligible à ce fameux permis
avec une telle réglementation
ngolo tenté n'aurait certainement pas pu
rejoindre leicester en 2015
le champion du monde n'avait alors
jamais été sélectionné avec l'équipe de
france
les grands gagnants de segré exit
pourrait de 4 les jeunes britanniques
puisque la fédération anglaise
souhaiteraient profiter de ce
chamboulement pour réduire le nombre
d'étrangers autorisés dans les clubs
passant de 17 à 12
[Musique]
voilà donc ce sujet de clément delcourt
on comprend bien que certains joueurs ne
pourront plus signer à l'avenir on a
l'exemple de paul pogba celui de dan
cole augmenté ya également riyad mahrez
par exemple l'international algérien de
leicester vous avez dit tout à l'heure
que dans ce cas là où n'auriez plus de
joueurs tels que cesc fabregas qui a
quitté barcelone âgé de 16 ans pour
venir à arsenal ça serait plus aussi
dire que les pays non toc l'europe n'est
plus même l'angleterre ne considérait
plus les joueurs venant d'europe les
considérait comme les joueurs venant
d'afrique ou venant d'autres continents
et donc ils ne pourront pas écouter
avant l'âge de 18 ans quelles
conséquences
c'est un petit peu rétrograde puisque
dans la mesure où je pense que c'est un
phénomène de globalisation le football
et globale quoi ça vient aussi au rugby
c'est un peu rétrograde mois enfin si
vous voulez mon avis puisque vous m'avez
venir je pense qu'ils vont trouver
déjà pendant un an vous r on va rien
entendre en personne ne va bouger parce
qu'il ya une année tampon un peu ici et
puis aux alentours du côté du mercato de
2021 enfin le celui de janvier 2021
vous allez voir qu'ils vont sortir cette
façon une règle un peu comme à la
norvège c'est à dire que la norvège
devait pas partie de l'union européenne
mais jouant norvégiens sont considérés
comme des européens
on sait que l'union européenne et la
grande bretagne enfin le royaume unis
discutent cette fameuse mode de
transition entre soft ou arbres exit à
l'issue de cette phase de transition il
va y avoir des accords qui vont être
renégociés ce que juridiquement c'est
possible c'est envisageable
c'est un flou pour l'instant on ne sait
pas ce qui va se passer mais ce qu'on
sait que sur les mouvements britannique
vient d'annoncer des critères pour des
gens qui veulent s'installer en moyenne
unis que ce soit des européens où les
non européens et il faut obtenir un
certain nombre de points un peu comme si
on veut aller s'installer en australie
et pour moi les footballeurs vont
remplir ce critère
au moins que s'ils parlent anglais parce
qu'ils ont une offre d'emploi ils vont
gagner suffisamment d'argent et
ont un talon spécialisés donc si on
applique ce critère ils ont le nombre de
points pour venir que ceux ci ont soit
internationaux pas mais on verra ce qui
va se passer voyez le mans parce qu'on
sait qu'il ya aussi une tension entre la
fédération qui aimait bien réduire le
nombre d'étrangers pour aider l'équipe
d'angleterre qui est qui s'améliore on a
vu ça à faire de la demi finale au
mondial la dernière fois et on a une
belle génération on en mettait
actuellement d'aiacciu peu d'ombré qui
joue actuellement en premier league
c'est moins d'écart en poissons donc ce
serait bien pour le football anglais
d'avoir un peu plus d'anglais mais pas
au point d'exclure des termes en manger
avenue donne a changé gérard comme vient
de le dire
david la fédération va peut-être
profiter de cela est-ce que du coup est
ce qu'il ya un combat entre les grands
clubs anglais que ce soit les deux
équipes de manchester arsenal chelsea
liverpool
donc vous avez été le manager et la
fédération anglaise de football qui
souhaitent boire comme bien de dire
david plus de jeunes jouer sur le
terrain
vous savez en 92 les 20 clubs de 1re
ligue
on constitue la première ligne et se
sont détachés pratiquement de la
fédération c'est à dire que la première
league la ligue il fallait qu'ils vont
pour nous de la de ce qui ne tourne
c'est comme si en fait les 20 clubs de
première division en france 1,2 de ligue
1 en france se détacher est constitué à
seule une entité à part dans une bulle à
part unique ferme et non pas une ferme
et pas du tout puisqu'il ya des
descentes et ou non simplement sur le
plan commercial sur le plan des droits
sur le banc télé ils sont complètement à
part et donc il n'y a pas un conflit
mais il ya quand même disons un peu leur
sentiment de la part de la fédération
qui elle heureusement j'ai rencontré tel
qui chapeaute en cours tout mais qui ne
contrôle plus qui n'a plus d'ordre à
donner la première ligne la première
league fait ses propres règlements
la seule chose c'est qu'ils vont être
confrontés aux règlements de l'état afin
que va décider état et je pense que
peut-être que dans un premier temps
ce qu'il a expliqué clairement c'est que
c'est un petit peu quand même
comme s'il voulait pour obtenir un
permis il faudrait un certain nombre de
points a permis de travail font un
certain nombre de points et on dira
toujours si on recrute un tel c'est
parce qu'il est très bon même s'il n'est
pas international
on peut vous pouvez il a été en
sélection de jeunes etc
c'est l'intérêt d'une manière des vingt
clubs de 1ère ligue d'avoir les
meilleurs joueurs parce que si comme
décision les meilleurs joueurs jean
meyer championnat et à partir de là il
est meilleur e
disons gains par rapport à la télévision
droite et et au droit à lison sponsoring
et tout donc pour avoir ce meilleur
joueur bail soit ils utiliseront disons
de dérogation dire c'est un talent
exceptionnel et puis soit simplement ils
recruteront façon les les tops le
meilleur quoi comme le hip hop bas
c'était un problème d'âge c'est pas
pareil mais pogba maintenant il faut
récupérer il faut qu'ils prouvent qu'ils
les stats alors exceptionnel et qu'il a
fait autant de matches avec l'équipe
nationale et qui parlent anglais
enfin il faut souligner que ta voix
autant d'étrangers c'est un phénomène
assez récent comme cantona est venu à
leeds et il était un joueur exotique
pour pour les gens qui suivaient le
football anglais parce que on avait
l'époque des argentins et ornements au
début des années 80 avec adil aziziya il
y avait donné l'idée à ipswich mais
sinon il y avait très peu d'être
changées l'étranger de l'aqip c'était
soit la cause chez soi les landais donc
c'est vraiment depuis 25 28 ans qu'on a
autant de joueurs étrangers dans le
championnat mais la mondialisation ce
brésil pour la première ligue anglaise
les frontières sont remises en place une
sorte de protectionnisme qui est
sincèrement je pense que ça va continuer
la premier league à ton tellement faute
est le plus grand championnat du monde
avec le plus d'argent
sauf s'il ya encore une fois sauf s'il
ya le taux de change
sa chute est spectaculaire mais je vois
pas
deux choses changer d'ici dix ans la
premier league c'est un produit anglais
donc c'est un produisons qui est
véhiculé pendant tous les pays grâce si
vous voulez grâce au fait c'est
l'angleterre qui partout dans le monde
entier avec la première ligue
je vois pas comment il pourrait de même
se mutiler en dix ans en réduisant le en
maison d'édition des conditions très
dures pour les étrangers pour venir le
rapt est un peu plus de papa serait
hissé tout c'est la fin de la première
mi-temps rester sur le plateau de
l'autre au match qui revient tout de
suite après ça de retour sur le plateau
de l'autre au match nos invités sont
toujours là ils n'ont pas changé
toujours gérard houllier ancien manager
de liverpool et david crowe san
journaliste anglais on est en train
d'évoquer les conséquences du mexique
sur sur la première league anglaise
pour vous la première league ne va pas
véritablement changé en tous les cas
peau pour le moment mais est ce que ça
peut changer le rapport de force entre
les clubs riches et les clubs moins
riches à savoir est ce que les équipes
du top 6 seront ils encore plus riches
et les autres clubs vont ils être encore
plus pauvres c'est possible c'est un
risque parce que le produit rare le
joueur d'exception où les internationaux
comprendrait des différents pays tels
que l'allemagne la france dali ou
l'espagne au portugal basse et ce sont
des joueurs qui porteront vont coûter
plus cher est que c'est possible que
c'est vrai que ça creuse à nouveau
l'écart en termes de résultats avec les
autres avec les autres équipes et donc
ça creuse également l'écart sur le plan
financier vous avez parlé entre eux
porter cela vous avez parlé des joueurs
vivent la plupart des entraîneurs aussi
c'est à guardiola quid de guardiola et
de clopes et c'est bon peut être que e
on pourrait dire voilà ils ont évolué
quand il ya eu dans leur pays donc par
contre quand ils peuvent venir mais il
ya beaucoup d'entraîneurs étrangers
notamment portugais qui démarre en
angleterre va en travers de hodgkin un
très bon manager mais ne pourrait pas
peut-être qu'il ne pourrait plus revenir
en angleterre quoi votre avis david est
ce qu'il peut y avoir un championnat à
deux vitesses suite au breakbeat ça
existe déjà
donc est-ce que ça va accentuer cet
effet ou pas je sais pas j'essaie
vraiment s'il ya un propriétaire qui
arrive quand on arrive à changer son
statut parce que sinon c'est très dur de
percer de tête en deux sorties sont pas
avoir le meilleur coach du monde mais
s'il n'a pas les joueurs on a on a des
résultats de temps en temps qui sont
atypiques comme
le championnat vont voter par l'est mais
sinon on voit quasiment les mêmes clubs
dans le top 6 à chaque saison il
ils échangent les places en jeu mais
c'est idiot on appelle ça le top 6 et
les 14 autres maintenant on omettait et
comme tu vois un match on ne veut une
équipe classée 11e à la 15e place à la
16e place on se demande pourquoi c'est
la ligue le plus riche du monde
donc il ya un problème de niveau selon
voulait le débat n'est n'est pas ici
mais on est parlé de leicester qui avait
été sacré champion il ya quelques années
et dans cette équipe de l'histoire il y
avait justement le cas de naulleau kanté
qui joue désormais pour l'équipe de
france mais quand même pas pu être
recruté s'il y avait eu le brésil y
avait également riyad mahrez on a évoqué
ce qui a si ces deux personnes n'avaient
pas été recruté par par leicester
peut-être que l'histoire n'aurait jamais
été sacré champion d'angleterre donc du
coup est ce que le phénomène
david qui peut battre goliath est-ce que
du coup ça n'existera plus dans le
championnat d'angleterre dans le
football y aura toujours des avis de
cuba sont des goliath ça c'est sûr
quelles que soient les règles que soient
les aura toujours un moment ou un autre
sur une saison pleine andré avait en
tout le monde mais sur une saison pleine
ça me semble plus difficile mais parce
que justement c'est l'exploit qu'ils
avaient réussi les stars assure une
saison de leicester c'était sur son
recrutement vous avez pas de quand et
quand et par exemple est pourquoi il
faut expliquer pourquoi quand emma reste
un peu plus avec le break cite par
exemple dur choix ben quoi trop
peut-être un soft est un dur veut
pré-écrit dur ni comptés ni mahrez jouer
dans leur sélection nationale à l'époque
donc on pouvait pas dire on appris des
grands talents ou des joueurs
exceptionnels qui joue dans l'eure avec
la compétition sélection nationale à
partir de là c'est vrai qu' il n'aurait
pas eu de permis de travail
mais même à l'époque il y avait un
système un peu plus strictes à on
pouvait demander des dérogations
donc on sait pas encore à quel point on
peut pousser ces dérogations est ce que
les clubs vont pouvoir a insisté pour
obtenir le joueur qui qu'ils aimeraient
bien à leur écoute et vous parlez de
paperasse au final plus de paperasse et
celle la finalité du brésil sauve
appelle ça va pas l unique et fait main
c'est un des effets pour les supporters
je pense qu'ils vont avoir à peu près le
même produit pour le problème va être
ailleurs c'est déjà le faubourg langues
les cultures est cher c'est cher un
abonnement pour aller voir son équipe
jouer longue états et les villes dont le
nom n'était qui ont voté pour le
président
oui ce que tu as touché par des
conséquences économiques donc ça va être
encore plus difficile d'aller payer son
abonnement
justement vous parlez des supporters
comment est-ce qu'ils le vivent le
parricide puisqu'on sait qu'un
supporteur britannique pour lui le foot
c'est quelque chose de sacré on va voir
un match de foot
le week end en famille d'ailleurs il ya
le boxing day en angleterre le lendemain
de noël
tout le monde va voir un match de foot
ou presse comment est ce qu'ils vivent
salle et les britanniques les anglais
les supporters on n'en parle pas chaud
pour l'instant parce qu'on n'a pas vu
les effets il va falloir poser la même
question de l'année prochaine mais même
d'ici deux trois ans parce que pour
l'instant rien ne change
et comme j'aime radis en début
d'émission les clubs vont pouvoir
continuer à recruter jusqu'à au 31
décembre 2020 et c'est à partir du 1er
janvier
donc on va voir ce qui va se passer on
parle de la presse des joueurs des
entraîneurs du public les médias il on
dise quoi les médias sportifs par
rapport à tout cela est sympa ils savent
pas quoi écrire parce que ils focalisent
beaucoup plus sur les résultats
magnifiques de liverpool
si jürgen klopp ou sur les problèmes des
clubs anglais en champion's league ces
dernières semaines que sur le proxy
parce que ça reste très théorique
on n'a pas d'effet à remonter dans le
papier on parlait tout à l'heure des
droits télé avec un nouveau contrat
signé avec la scandinavie
les contrats mirobolants de la première
ligue à l'étranger il faut savoir
également qu'elle les avait un coeur
vont suivre vous allez voir que le
prochain gros contrat ce sera les
américains mais justement il ya des gros
contrats et dans le côté il ya ce break
site avec 7 vous dites vous le dit
régulièrement on ne sait pas du coup il
ya un phénomène d'incertitude
malgré le phénomène d'incertitude on
continue d'acheter les droits télé pour
diffuser la première league anglaise
est-ce que ça ça va continuer est-ce
qu'il va pas y avoir cette incertitude
dans dans les esprits qui va s'immiscer
qui du coup va faire chuter les prix et
ainsi créer un cercle vicieux
moi je pense que d'abord se réguler de
soi même c'est à dire que premièrement
je vois je vois très bien disons et les
clubs puissants s'organiser et dire vous
ne pouvez pas nous empêcher de prendre
un anglais à deux points d'un français
en allemand et c'est parce que bon vous
l'autorisez au norvégien pourquoi pas
nous quoi autrement dit ils vont trouver
les règles qui seront peut-être des
règles disons d'exception pour eux qui
leur permettront de continuer de manière
à fonctionner quand ils vous roulez les
autres coupes et des clubs puissants
mais comment vont réagir les petits
clubs par rapport justement avec
dérogations et au fait que les clubs
puissants se mettent ensemble va pas y
avoir un phénomène d'injustice non non
pas du tout parce que eux pourront
justement peut-être faire ce qu'a fait
leicester c'est à dire repéré un deux ou
trois joueurs qui sont en devenir
donc ils ne sont pas trop connus et les
faire venir pour justement développer
leur club
non j'ai pas du tout je pense pas que de
ça des jouant en faveur des petits clubs
ont parlé également de
du combat qui oppose les grands clubs à
la fédération des jeunes joueurs de
l'union européenne qui pourront plus
venir mais il ya sens inverse
également on pense à dortmund qui a un
joueur qui s'appelle sans le show qui a
un qui est un jeune anglais est là dans
le sens inverse ça va également se
produire ça veut dire que là que
l'angleterre va conserver
ses meilleurs joueurs parce que là c'est
un point positif justement lui qui
évolue à dortmund
la france doit servir un faux chantier
qui joue aussi bien à dormund pour la
sélection anglaise c'est un point très
positif et pas que lui et les autres
jeunes anglais qui sont partis là bas et
ils n'ont pas de problème d'adaptation
parce que les amants pas très bien le
l'onglet mais non je pense que à
l'avenir les meilleurs talents anglais
ou a déjà ils vont rester plus ou moins
on en mettait parce que les anglais
n'aiment pas choo s'exiler il faut en
être il y en a très peu qui parlent une
langue étrangère mais ce qui est
intéressant à dénoncer que les écossais
les irlandais du nord est considérées
comme des transferts internationaux
aussi avec les nouveaux règlements parce
que on a l'équipe anglaise mais il ya
aussi la sélection écossaise la salle à
notre sélection 10 long du nom donc du
coup ils eux ils vont être considéré
comme étranger aussi et ça ça peut avoir
un effet très négatif pour se doper la
justement pour par exemple les causes on
pense au celtic aux rangers ce qu' elle
quelles conséquences pour pour les
causes qu'elle conséquents souligne le
dire pour pompes pour l'irlande du nord
par exemple il va falloir regarder tu es
loin parce que on sait que c'est un
écossais aimerait bien quitter le
royaume uni pour mieux voir venir faire
partie de l'union européenne
donc on voit et quelles conséquences
pour les clubs français de ligue 1 qui y
vont de leurs joueurs en angleterre
à bayeux il regarde ça de manière très
cher et très très attentif parce que je
pense que les meilleurs se vendront plus
cher mais que le joueur moyen lui a
beaucoup plus de difficultés de 66 et
encore une fois un bon exemple qui est
dur c'est après critique et doux qui
disons plus constant sera différent du
cerveau exceed qui est dur je vous dis
vous avez un joueur moyen qui n'a pas de
sélection même si pour n'avoir pu da ne
pourra pas venir jouer en angleterre
comme ça il peut y avoir un président du
rpt
au final
mais est ce que dans le même temps il
peut y avoir un break site d'où même
temps le football est ce que c'est
possible ça ou est-ce que c'est
complètement rien c'est aussi possible
le folk peut faire preuve d' exception
parce que comme gérard a dit tout à
l'heure ça fait voyez on est longue le
tas dans le monde entier quand même
partout on voyage s'ils te dis à
quelqu'un moi je suis anglais il parle
tout de suite du football on parlait
tout à l'heure du taux de change entre
l'euro la livre sterling
on sait qu'elle est montée jusqu'à 1,8
un une livre égal à 1,8 euro
maintenant c'est à peu près 1 euros 20
mai à l'avenir s'il ya
une dévaluation de la livre sterling
escape à un risque parce que certains
craignent que cela notamment un avocat
de d'agents de joueurs qui s'appelle
thierry granturco qui a déclaré à offre
égale quand il ya un grand club espagnol
ou un grand club anglais qui vous
approche soit vous négociez des
sécurités mirobolantes avec le club
anglais soit vous allez voir en espagne
parce qu'il y a pas de risque
est ce que justement un grand joueur va
préférer aller en espagne ou en italie
plutôt que d'aller en angleterre non
c'est précieux
il y aura ainsi la possibilité il y
avait en angleterre
l'angleterre est le pays qui attire le
plus les joueurs ça vaut le savoir et du
coup on va faire des découdre en euro
pour éviter que les joueurs perdent de
l'argent c'est possible ça va ça peut
devenir très technique parce que
l'angleterre loi et mini peut aussi
changer sa fiscalité pour vendre de plus
attractifs aux étrangers qui aimeraient
bien s'installer en angleterre donc
finalité rien de rien ne va changer la
première league anglaise va rester la
première league anglaise exit en existe
non si vous voulez mon avis je pense que
peut-être pour les jeunes ça changera il
produit il ya un espèce de compromis
c'est-à-dire que si on ne prend pas
peut-être un genou avant 18 ans comme on
ne peut pas prendre un africain ou un
joueur d'un autre continent avant 18 ans
peut-être que ça ça ça ça viendra en
angleterre et ça protégera les jeunes
anglais après je dirais que ils vont
trouver un joug d un système un peu
comme ils l'ont trouvé un moment avec la
norvège
personne n'en parle mais norvégien et
soco design comme des les joueurs
européens alors qu'un large débat et de
l'union européenne avec notamment le
jeune joueur allende qui évolue du côté
de mort qui a notamment performer face à
face au paris saint germain
messieurs merci beaucoup d'être venu sur
ce plateau de l'autre au match pour
parler donc du breakbeat et de la
première league anglaise est ce que le
président va tuer la première league
anglaise la réponse ici sur ce plateau
on a compris c'est donc non merci
messieurs et
et on peut revivre évidemment évidemment
cette émission sur rtl france point tv
et sinon ce rendez vous évidemment la
semaine prochaine pour un nouveau numéro
de l'autre match à plus sur arte france
mme abbey
[Musique]